OVERSAW.
HE WAS RIGHT.
WE ARE GOING TO SHOW YOU ALL
THIS AND MORE INTIMATES VERY
IMPORTANT BREAKING NEWS OPENING
MONOLOGUE.
THE PRESIDENT JUST WRAPPED UP A
HUGE, RAUCOUS, FUN RALLY IN
INDIANA.
WILL BRING YOU ALL THE
HIGHLIGHTS THROUGHOUT THE SHOW.
HERE IS JUST A SMALL SAMPLE OF
WHAT WENT DOWN.
TAKE A LOOK.
>> IF WE WOULD'VE TOLD YOU
DURING THE CAMPAIGN THAT WE
WOULD CREATE 3.3 MILLION JOBS IN
THIS SHORT TIME, EVERYBODY BACK
THERE, THE FAKE NEWS MEDIA.
LOOK AT ALL OF THEM.
[BOOING]
FAKE NEWS.
EVERYBODY BACK THERE WOULD HAVE
SAID, CAN YOU IMAGINE?
HE IS SAYING WE ARE GOING TO
CREATE 3.3 MILLION.
CAN YOU BELIEVE IT.
YOU HAVE TO WORK EVERY DAY
BETWEEN NOW AND NOVEMBER TO
ELECT MORE REPUBLICANS SO THAT
WE CONTINUE MAKING AMERICA GREAT
AGAIN.
AND BY THE WAY, THIS IS THE
FIRST FOUR INDIANA.
OUR NEW SLOGAN FOR 2020, DO YOU
KNOW WHAT IT IS?
KEEP AMERICA GREAT.
>> Sean: WE WILL HAVE MORE ON
THE PRESIDENTS RALLY IN A MOMENT
BUT FIRST A GREAT DAY FOR THIS
COUNTRY AND OUR FELLOW
COUNTRYMEN BECAUSE EARLY THIS
MORNING THE PLANE CARRYING THREE
OF OUR FELLOW AMERICANS WHO HAD
BEEN HELD HOSTAGE IN NORTH KOREA
FOR MONTHS, THEY TOUCHED DOWN IN
JOINT BASE ANDREWS.
OUR PRAYERS WERE ANSWERED.
THESE THREE MEN CAME BACK IN
GOOD HEALTH, AND WE SHOULD ALL
BE PROUD OF THE OUTSTANDING WORK
THIS COUNTRY DID TO BRING OUR
FELLOW AMERICANS HOME APPEARED
PRESIDENT TRUMP THAT THE THREE
FORMER HOSTAGES ON THE TARMAC
AND DELIVERED THESE HOPEFUL
REMARKS ABOUT 3:00 A.M. IN THE
MORNING LAST NIGHT.
>> WE WANT TO THINK KIM JONG UN
WHO REALLY WAS EXCELLENT TO
THESE THREE INCREDIBLE PEOPLE.
THEY ARE REALLY INCREDIBLE
PEOPLE.
THE FACT THAT WE WERE ABLE TO
GET THEM OUT SO SOON WAS REALLY
A TRIBUTE TO A LOT OF THINGS,
INCLUDING A CERTAIN PROCESS
THAT'S TAKING PLACE RIGHT NOW.
IN THAT PROCESS IS VERY
IMPORTANT.
SO WE WILL SEE WHAT HAPPENS.
WE HAVE A MEETING SCHEDULED IN A
VERY SHORT.
LACK OF TIME.
YOU'LL BE HEARING ABOUT IT SOON.
WE HAVE THE LOCATION SET AND WE
WILL SEE IF WE CAN DO SOMETHING
PEOPLE DO NOT THINK WAS GOING TO
HAPPEN FOR MANY, MANY YEARS.
A LOT OF BAD THINGS COULD HAVE
HAPPENED IN BETWEEN.
>> Sean: THIS WAS A VERY
IMPORTANT DIPLOMATIC VICTORY.
WE KNOW THE DANGER THESE THREE
AMERICANS FACE BECAUSE WE SAW
WHAT HAPPENED TO OTTO WARMBIER,
THE AMERICAN COLLEGE STUDENT
HELD CAPTIVE IN NORTH KOREA
WHICH ULTIMATELY CAUSED HIS
HORRIFIC DEATH.
THE OTTO WARMBIER FAMILY REMAIN
IN OUR PRAYERS.
TONIGHT WE HAVE A REASON TO FEEL
HOPEFUL AND PROUD.
THREE AMERICAN LIVES WERE LIKELY
SAVED AND WE DIDN'T HAVE TO
BRIBE KIM JONG UN OR SEND
PALLETS OF CASH TO NORTH KOREA
TO GET THE JOB DONE.
SLOW IN THE MAINSTREAM MEDIA, AS
CORRUPT AS THEY ARE, THEY MERELY
YAWNED TODAY.
"THE NEW YORK TIMES" BURIED THE
STORY.
ABC NEWS CRITICIZED
PRESIDENT TRUMP ON IRAN.
THE LIBERAL SENATOR FROM
NEW YORK CHUCK SCHUMER WAS LESS
THAN PLEASED.
REALLY?
THREE AMERICANS SAVED, BACK
HOME.
YOU ARE NOT PLEASE, YOU ARE NOT
HAPPY?
TAKE A LOOK AT THIS.
>> THE EXULTATION BY THE
PRESIDENT AND OTHERS OF THE
GREATNESS OF NORTH KOREA DOING
THIS EVADES ME.
HE CAN'T BE FOOLED INTO GIVING
THE NORTH KOREAN REGIME CREDIT
FOR RETURNING AMERICANS THAT
NEVER SHOULD'VE BEEN DETAINED IN
THEIR FIRST PLACE.
AMERICAN CITIZENS ARE NOT
DIPLOMATIC BARGAINING CHIPS.
THERE REALLY SHOULD NOT BE
EXALTED.
IT SHOULD BE EXPECTED.
IT IS NO GREAT ACCOMPLISHMENT OF
KIM JONG UN TO DO THIS.
WHEN THE PRESIDENT DOES IT, HE
WEAKENS AMERICAN FOREIGN POLICY
AND PUTS AMERICANS AT RISK
AROUND THE WORLD.
>> Sean: WHAT DO YOU THINK
ABOUT THIS?
A FRIEND OF MINE, GREAT DOCTOR,
BRAIN SURGEON, TALK ABOUT THIS
EARLIER.
HE SAID WHAT A JERK.
THIS COMES FROM ONE OF THE
SMARTEST, BRIGHTEST BRAIN
SURGEON THE WORLD.
YOU ARE RIGHT.
THIS IS ONE SAD CASE OF TRUMP
DERANGEMENT SYNDROME.
CHUCKIE, IT'S OKAY TO BE PROUD
OF YOUR COUNTRY.
LIVES WERE SAVED.
WHILE SCHUMER IS WHINING,
PRESIDENT TRUMP IS CONTINUOUS
PUSH FOR PEACE ULTIMATELY IN THE
KOREAN PENINSULA.
TODAY HE MADE AN IMPORTANT
ANNOUNCEMENT HE TWEETED:
"THE HIGHLY ANTICIPATED MEETING
BETWEEN KIM JONG UN AND MYSELF
WILL TAKE PLACE IN SINGAPORE ON
JUNE 12TH.
WE WILL BOTH TRY TO MAKE IT
A VERY SPECIAL MOMENT
FOR WORLD PEACE!"
OF COURSE WE CAN'T PREDICT THE
FUTURE.
KIM JONG UN IS FRANKLY AND
UNTRUSTWORTHY.
COME, UNBREAKABLE DESPERATE.
GIVEN ALL NORTH KOREA'S
CONCESSIONS, WE HAVE REASON TO
BE CAUTIOUSLY OPTIMISTIC.
THE KOREAN PENINSULA PROGRESSING
TOWARDS PEACE.
TENSIONS IN THE MIDDLE EAST ARE
RISING, AS WE REPORTED LAST
NIGHT, THE ISRAELI DEFENSE
FORCES I NOTICED THAT IRAN FIRED
OVER A DOZEN MISSILES FROM SYRIA
INTO ISRAEL FROM THEIR
INSTALLATIONS IN SYRIA.
NO CASUALTIES, THANKFULLY, WE
REPORTED.
THE IRON DOME INTERCEPTED MANY
PROJECTILES.
HOURS AGO ISRAEL RIGHTFULLY
RESPONDING IN A MASSIVE WAY,
LAUNCHING A FULL-SCALE AERIAL
ATTACK AGAINST IRAN'S FORCES IN
SYRIA, AND THEY TOOK OUT DOZENS
OF MILITARY SITES, ANTIAIRCRAFT
BATTERIES AND REPORTEDLY KILLING
DOZENS OF THOSE THAT ARE
COMMITTING THESE ACTS OF TERROR.
UNLIKE MANY COUNTRIES, ISRAEL
CAN NEVER PUT THEIR GUARD DOWN.
THEY DON'T HAVE THAT LUXURY.
WHEN IT RAINS ON ISRAEL, THERE
WILL BE A FLOOD ON ISRAEL'S
ENEMIES.
THIS CONFLICT WITH IRAN IS NO
DIFFERENT.
IN FACT, IRAN'S INVOLVEMENT IN
PROXY WARS ALL OVER THE
MIDDLE EAST HAS LONG BEEN A
THREAT TO THE SECURITY AND THE
PEACE OF THE ISRAELI PEOPLE AND
OF COURSE AMERICAN TROOPS THAT
ARE STATIONED IN SYRIA, IRAQ,
AND ELSEWHERE.
YOU HAVE THE MULLAHS OF IRAN
LONG CHANTING DEATH TO AMERICA,
DEATH TO ISRAEL, BURNING OUR
FLIGHT, BURNING THEIR FLAG.
THEY BACK UP THOSE WORDS BY
WHITE, FINDING THE MOST RADICAL
TERRORISTS IN THE WORLD, SENDING
TRAINED FIGHTERS ALL OVER THE
MIDDLE EAST TO KILL OUR SOLDIERS
IN IRAQ AND OUR ALLY'S SOLDIERS.
THIS IS A CHEAP REASON FOR THE
CURRENT MILITARY STRIKE IN SYRIA
AND LIKELY PLAYED A KEY ROLE IN
PRESIDENT TRUMP'S RIGHT DECISION
TO PULL OUT OF THAT HORRIFIC
IRANIAN DEAL.
A FEW MOMENTS AGO, THE PRESIDENT
WRAPPED UP THE RALLY IN INDIANA.
HE SPOKE ABOUT IRAN AND
NORTH KOREA AND SO MUCH MORE.
TAKE A LOOK.
>> ON JUNE 12, IN SINGAPORE, I
WILL BE MEETING WITH KIM JONG UN
TO PURSUE A FUTURE OF PEACE AND
SECURITY FOR THE WORLD, FOR THE
WHOLE WORLD.
BUT YOU REMEMBER, EVERYBODY, IN
THE FAKE NEWS WHEN THEY WERE
SAYING HE'S GOING TO GET US INTO
A NUCLEAR WAR!
HE'S GOING TO GET US INTO A
NUCLEAR WAR.
AND YOU KNOW WHAT GETS YOU INTO
NUCLEAR WARS AND YOU KNOW WHAT
GETS YOU INTO OTHER WARS:
WEAKNESS.
I THINK IT'S GOING TO BE A VERY
BIG SUCCESS, BUT MY ATTITUDE IS,
AND IF IT ISN'T, IT ISN'T, OKAY.
IF IT IS THE END, IT ISN'T BUT,
AND YOU HAVE TO HAVE THAT
BECAUSE YOU DON'T KNOW.
WE ARE NOT GOING TO BE WALKING
INTO AN IRAN DEAL WHERE THE
NEGOTIATORS JOHN KERRY REFUSED
TO LEAVE THE TABLE.
OBAMA, PRESIDENT OBAMA.
PAID 1.8 BILLION FOR HOSTAGES.
YOU, NOT ME, YOU.
LAST NIGHT YOU SIGHED AND BEGAN
ITS LEADING TO SOME VERY BIG
THINGS, AND I THINK THAT
KIM JONG UN, KIM JONG UN DID A
GREAT SERVICE TO HIMSELF, TO HIS
COUNTRY BY DOING THIS.
BUT THOSE HOSTAGES CAME OUT WITH
RESPECT.
WE DIDN'T PAY FOR THEM.
WE'RE GOING TO SET THE TABLE.
WE'RE GOING TO MAKE A GREAT DEAL
FOR THE WORLD FOR NORTH KOREA,
FOR SOUTH KOREA, FOR JAPAN, FOR
CHINA.
>> Sean: TOUTING THE KEY TO
VELTMAN'S ON THE WORLD STAGE,
VICE PRESIDENT MIKE PENCE IS
BACKING THEM UP RIGHT HERE AT
HOME.
DURING THE INTERVIEW EARLIER
TODAY, THE VICE PRESIDENT TOLD
ABC THAT IT'S TIME FOR MUELLER'S
WITCH HUNT, AND I AGREE
COMPLETELY, TO COME TO AN END.
TAKE A LOOK.
>> OUR ADMINISTRATION HAS BEEN
FULLY COOPERATING WITH THE
SPECIAL COUNSEL.
>> DO YOU THINK THE
INVESTIGATION IS A HOAX?
>> WE WILL CONTINUE TO.
WHAT I THINK IS THAT IT'S BEEN
ABOUT A YEAR SINCE THIS
INVESTIGATION BEGAN.
OUR ADMINISTRATION HAS PROVIDED
OVER A MILLION DOCUMENTS.
WE FULLY COOPERATED AND IT IN
THE INTEREST OF THE COUNTRY, I
THINK IT'S TIME TO WRAP IT UP.
>> Sean: TIME TO WRAP IT UP, I
AGREE.
MEANWHILE ACCORDING TO SOME
STELLAR REPORTING, GET FROM OUR
OWN SARA CARTER, WE KNOW THAT
THE FORMER FBI DIRECTOR JAMES
COMEY, THE ONE ROD ROSENSTEIN'S
HAD TO FIRE, HE CONSULTED WITH
TEAM MUELLER BEFORE GIVING ANY
TESTIMONY TO CONGRESS ABOUT ITS
INQUIRY INTO RUSSIA.
CAN ANYONE SAY COLLUSION OR
COLLABORATION, INAPPROPRIATE?
JUDICIAL WATCH HAS ACQUIRED THE
EMAILS THAT SHOW COORDINATION IN
THESE EFFORTS BETWEEN THE OFFICE
OF SPECIAL COUNSEL AND THE
DISGRACED FORMER FBI DIRECTOR.
IN OTHER WORDS, YOU HAVE DEEP
STATE NEWS HERE.
REMEMBER LAST NIGHT WHEN WE
REPORTED THE MEETING BETWEEN ROD
ROSENSTEIN, INTEL COMMITTEE
CHAIR DEVIN NUNES, AND OVERSIGHT
COMMITTEE CHAIRMAN TREY GOWDY.
THAT MEETING WAS CLASSIFIED BUT
IT WAS SUPPOSED TO ADDRESS THE
DOJ'S ONGOING STONEWALLING, SLOW
WALKING OF DOCUMENTS THAT HAVE
BEEN SUBPOENAED BY CONGRESS.
OH, THEN THEY GIVE THE PHONY
REDACTION.
OH, AND THEY'D DELAY DELAY,
DELAY.
THEN THEY SAY NO.
ACCORDING TO A BRAND-NEW ARTICLE
FROM SARA CARTER, THIS COULD BE
JUST AN EFFORT TO BUY TIME FOR
SESSIONS AND ROSENSTEIN.
WE WILL HAVE MORE ON THIS LATER
IN THE SHOW.
THIS STUFF IS NOT FUN.
THE AMERICAN PEOPLE HAVE A RIGHT
TO KNOW.
THE CONSTITUTION GIVES CONGRESS
THAT OVERSIGHT RESPONSIBILITY.
MAKE NO MISTAKE.
WE ON THIS PROGRAM, WILL HOLD
THE ATTORNEY GENERAL JEFF
SESSIONS, WROTE ROSENSTEIN,
DEPUTY ATTORNEY GENERAL, AND
ANYONE
ELSE ACTIVELY OBSTRUCTING
CONSTITUTIONAL RATIONAL
OVERSIGHT TO CONROE.
WE HAVE NEW DEVELOPMENTS
SURROUNDING THE CONFIRMATION
PROCESS OF PRESIDENT TRUMP PICK
TO HEAD THE CIA.
HER NAME, YOU SEE RIGHT THERE,
AN AMAZING APPEARANCE BEFORE
CONGRESS.
GINA HASPEL.
DEMOCRATS ARE OPPOSING HER
BECAUSE THEY THINK THE ENHANCED
INTERROGATION PROGRAM SHE
OVERSAW WAS TOO TOUGH ON
TERRORISTS LIKE KHALID SHEIKH
MOHAMMED.
THE GUY THAT WAS THE MASTERMIND
BEHIND 9/11.
FORMER VICE PRESIDENT
DICK CHENEY, HE'S NOT BUYING IT.
HE IS DEAD ON ACCURATE.
EARLIER TODAY, HE CAME OUT
SWINGING.
GOOD FOR THE FORMER
VICE PRESIDENT.
WATCH THIS.
>> WHAT WE DID WAS IN FACT AND
CONSISTENT WITH OUR FUNDAMENTAL
STATUTES.
IT WORKED.
I THINK WHAT WE DID HELPED
ULTIMATELY PRODUCE THE
INTELLIGENCE WE NEEDED TO BE
ABLE TO GET BIN LADEN.
IF IT WERE MY CALL, I WOULD NOT
DISCONTINUE THOSE PROGRAMS.
I WOULD HAVE THEM ACTIVE AND
READY TO GO.
YOU TELL ME THAT THE ONLY METHOD
WE HAVE THIS PLEASE, PLEASE,
PRETTY PLEASE TELL US WHAT YOU
KNOW.
I DON'T BUY THAT.
I THINK THE TECHNIQUES WE USE
WERE NOT TORTURED.
PEOPLE ARE GOING TO GO BACK AND
TRY TO REWRITE HISTORY.
IF IT WERE MY CALL, IT WOULD DO
IT AGAIN.
>> Sean: OF COURSE HE
VICE PRESIDENT DICK CHENEY IS
RIGHT.
INTERROGATION OF KHALID SHEIKH
MOHAMMED, IT LED TO THE COURIER.
THAT CAREER LETTUCE WHERE USAMA
BIN LADEN WAS.
IT'S TIME FOR DEMOCRATIC
SENATORS TO PUT THE SAFETY OF
YOU, THE AMERICAN PEOPLE, AHEAD
OF THEIR PERSONAL HATRED OF
PRESIDENT TRUMP.
WE NEED TO CONFIRM PEOPLE,
HEROES LIKE GINA HASPEL, AS SOON
AS POSSIBLE.
WITHOUT A DOUBT, SHE'S AN
AMERICAN HERO.
SHE IS THE RIGHT CHOICE TO LEAD
THE CIA.
BY THE WAY, CLAIRE McCASKILL,
WHERE ARE YOU?
HEIDI HEITKAMP, WHERE ARE YOU ON
THIS?
WE NEED A STRONG CIA.
ONE THAT DOES NOT USE THE